As Game of Thrones moved towards its epic
conclusion, almost every action shed new light
on something that had been said before.
From cryptic prophecies to long-awaited callbacks,
here are the lines that deserve a little extra
attention — even the shortest sentences
might have more meaning than you think.
Bran's transition from young, naive boy to
the Three-Eyed Raven and ruler of the Kingdoms
of Westeros was a plotline that ran through
the entire series, from the first episode
to the last.
As he became more and more omniscient, he
essentially became a totally different person
— or non-person, as the case may be.
As each of the Stark siblings reunites with
Bran, they gradually figure out that he's
turned a bit… well, odd.
Neither Sansa nor Arya seem to be able to
make any sense out of his proclamation that
he's the Three-Eyed Raven, although they do
use his talents to hold Littlefinger accountable
for his crimes.
In the season eight premiere, Jon Snow finally
meets back up with his long lost little brother,
and sets up one of Bran's most cryptic lines
of dialogue:
"Look at you.
You're a man."
"Almost."
In the context of the final episode, Bran's
reply here takes on an entirely different
meaning.
Not only does it indicate that he's not quite
a regular man as the Three-Eyed Raven, the
"almost" hints that he still has a major piece
of his destiny to fulfill: being named as
the new king.
"Why do you think I came all this way?"
It's not surprising that Jaime Lannister's
return to Winterfell brings with it some fairly
awkward reunions, considering that the last
time he came to visit to the Northern castle,
he tried to kill a child by shoving the poor
kid out of a window.
As we're all well aware, though, Jaime the
Kingslayer has plenty of other sins under
his belt that go beyond his long-running affair
with his own sister.
Of course, nobody besides Bran knows that
Jaime is the man who tried to kill him all
those years ago.
"The things I do for love."
As Jaime stands in front of both the Stark
and Targaryen factions at Winterfell, ready
to answer for his crimes, he comes face to
face with Bran himself.
He seems to be steeling himself for the moment
where Bran reveals one of Jaime's worst moments,
but that revelation never comes.
Instead, Bran simply echoes Jaime's exact
words from the moment where Jaime pushed him
out of that tower.
"The things we do for love."
This ultimately lets Jaime know that despite
Bran's long journey to become the Three-Eyed
Raven, a being who seems beyond concepts like
revenge and forgiveness, he'll never forget
what Jaime once did to him.
One of the season's most heartbreaking moments
comes right after the assault on Daenerys
and her fleet.
After losing one of her dragons, Rhaegal,
to one of Qyburn's scorpion spear launchers,
her ships are attacked by Euron Greyjoy.
In the skirmish, Missandei, who has long been
one of Daenerys' most trusted advisors, is
kidnapped by Greyjoy soldiers.
Tragically, Missandei ends up losing her life
so Cersei can prove a twisted point to Daenerys.
Offered the opportunity to speak her last
words, Missandei gives her final response.
"Dracarys."
Fans of Thrones will recognize this as the
command Daenerys uses to make her dragons
breathe fire on her enemies, but it means
even more to Missandei: the first time she
ever saw Daenerys use it, the Mother of Dragons
employed it against a slave owner in who once
owned and abused Missandei, which ultimately
freed her.
“Dracarys."
Even though Missandei can't directly unleash
dragonfire with her last words, it's one last
reminder of how much Daenerys has given her
and how much power and love Daenerys inspires
in her subjects — as well as the burning
rage Cersei has now unleashed.
Jaime and Cersei Lannister have been inextricably
linked, often physically, since the very beginning
of the show.
Even after the show's seventh season, when
Jaime left his sister behind after she threatened
to kill him, viewers knew that their destinies
were still intertwined, and the only question
was how.
Still, it might've been a little surprising
when, after years of character development
and a slow-burn romance, Jaime left Brienne
and his Northern allies behind to rejoin his
twin-slash-lover.
After a fight to the death with Euron, he
still returns to his true love and queen in
a last-ditch attempt to escape.
When the two find their path entirely blocked
as the ceiling begins to cave in above them,
Jaime says something that explains all of
his actions:
"Nothing else matters.
Nothing else matters.
Only us."
Since the beginning, these two have stuck
together, and as Jaime told Brienne back in
Winterfell, almost every evil act he committed
was in service to her.
For Jaime, a few years of playing the role
of a good guy just aren't enough to erase
those sins.
To him, the only thing real is his relationship
with Cersei, and they deserve to die together.
After her victory at King's Landing, Daenerys
disappears for a few victory laps on Drogon
the Dragon before returning to her newly conquered
city.
Landing at the ruins of the Red Keep, Daenerys
addresses her Unsullied and Dothraki army,
giving off distinctly tyrannical vibes as
she informs her troops that their war is far
from over..
It's tempting to think that Daenerys would
be satisfied in her quest for world domination
now that she has killed her rival queen and
taken the capital city.
She's even giving this speech while standing
above Cersei's body, buried in the rubble
beneath her.
Instead, she asks her armies to join her in
"liberating" every person in Westeros.
"Will you break the wheel with me?"
The speech is made to an overwhelming roar,
but at this point, the only wheel left to
break is the one of conquest that Dany's going
to roll across the continent.
Daenerys has always pledged to rid the world
of injustice, but in her quest for total control
of every inch of the Seven Kingdoms, it becomes
frighteningly apparent that she's more power-hungry
than anyone anticipated.
After resigning from his position as Hand
of the Queen due to Daenerys "slaughtering
a city" that had already surrendered, Tyrion
is taken into captivity to await his fate,
which will most likely come in the form of
being roasted by dragon fire, just like his
pal Varys.
While in captivity, Tyrion is visited by Jon
Snow, who is equally troubled by Daenerys'
decision to kill thousands of innocents in
King's Landing.
Jon initially insists he's still firmly on
her side, but over the course of the conversation,
Tyrion's bluntness seems to get through.
There's an especially crucial moment when
Tyrion offers up a reminder that it's not
just Jon's life that's in danger, since he's
the actual true heir, but that his rebellious
sister Sansa probably won't last long against
the conquering dragon queen, either.
It was all well and good when Daenerys was
destroying slavers, captors, and other evil
men, but now she's hell-bent on destroying
anybody in her path, whether or not they truly
deserve to die.
When Tyrion tells Jon that love often overcomes
reason, Jon offers up a memorable proverb
in response.
"Love is
the death of duty."
"You just came up with that?"
The line actually came from Maester Aemon
Targaryen, with whom Jon spent time during
his first stint with the Night's Watch at
Castle Black.
Tyrion, however, has an equally sage response:
"Sometimes duty is the death of love."
With that line, Tyrion leads Jon to his inevitable
fate, and the realization that Jon must kill
Daenerys to protect Westeros.
With that, Jon leaves to give Dany one last
chance to step back from the edge of world-conquering
madness, and when she doesn't, he does his
duty at last.
In a pretty great twist of fate, all three
surviving Stark children end up right where
it seems like they wanted to be back during
the first episode.
Sansa is the beautiful queen that she always
fantasized about becoming, Jon is off to join
the Night's Watch (again), and Arya has become
the skilled, fearsome adventurer she always
wanted to be.
During the tearful goodbye between them, Jon
even insists that Arya's welcome to come visit
him up North.
Castle Black might technically forbid women
from entering its gates, but Jon is pretty
realistic about the fact that nobody would
be able to stop her.
However, the younger of the Stark women tells
him she won't be able to visit.
She has other plans.
"I'm not going back north."
“Where are you going?”
"What's west of Westeros?"
It's unsurprising that Arya is already planning
her escape from Westeros.
Ever since her time exploring Braavos, she's
been hard to pin down, and now that the Realm
is safe in the hands of her brother, it's
about time for her next adventure.
There's a whole unknown world out there for
her to explore.
After saying her farewells to her sister and
brothers, that's where she heads.
In the episode's closing shots, viewers see
Arya one last time, gathering her weapons
and arranging maps before proudly strolling
along a grand ship, which turns out to be
adorned with the symbols of House Stark.
No matter where she goes, she'll always have
Winterfell with her.
Samwell Tarly was never a great fighter, but
since he managed to defy all the odds and
fan expectations to survive to the final episode
of the series, it was clear that he would
have a huge role to play during the ending
of Game of Thrones.
A bookish and somewhat sheepish figure, Sam's
strength was always in his studies, from the
time he did enough research on greyscale to
cure Jorah Mormont's affliction to the time
he helped Bran confirm Jon's true heritage
as Aegon Targaryen.
This all comes to a head during the series
finale, when Sam, dressed in the white robes
of a Maester and a part of Tyrion's Small
Council, presents the Hand of the King with
an enormous book written by the Archmaester,
with whom Sam worked with at the Citadel.
Confirming a long-held fan theory that Sam
would write or at least help write the history
of Westeros since Robert's Rebellion, Sam
reveals that the name of the tome is A Song
of Ice and Fire.
"I helped him with the title."
This is, of course, the same title that author
George R.R. Martin gave to the series of books
on which Game of Thrones was based.
As a survivor of all eight seasons, Sam was
present for many of the major events of the
series, so if he was meant to play the role
of a stand-in for Martin, that seems like
a perfectly fitting end for his character.
Maybe he'll be the one to finally finish writing
The Winds of Winter and A Dream of Spring.
With all of our usual suspects for who would
sit on the Iron Throne either dead or imprisoned
and the throne itself melted into slag, the
time comes for the remaining cast members
to choose a new leader of Westeros.
That's when Tyrion is brought before a new
council led by the last remaining members
of the Seven Kingdoms' great houses, including
Yara Greyjoy, the entire Stark family, an
unnamed Dornish prince, and long-lost faces
like Robyn Arryn and Edmure Tully, who gets
dunked on so viciously that he might never
recover.
"Uncle?
Please sit."
Tyrion is nominally there to stand trial for
betraying the queen, so it seems unlikely
that he'd get the chance to suggest the next
ruler of Westeros himself.
As usual, however, he's full of surprises.
Asked if he would like to rule, he says that
he doesn't want it, but having had some time
to mull it over, he's made up his mind about
the best candidate, and he reached his conclusion
for a pretty surprising reason.
He tells the assembled nobles that stories
are the most powerful things in the world,
and then makes his endorsement.
"Who has a better story than Bran the Broken?"
By suggesting Bran Stark as the next King
of Westeros, as well as suggesting that all
future rulers should be chosen by a council
rather than simply born into their title,
Tyrion finally breaks the wheel Daenerys fought
so hard to destroy, introducing a more merit-based
system of monarchy into the Seven Kingdoms.
"You've had a strange journey."
"Stranger than most."
Perhaps surprisingly, everyone assembled agrees,
deciding that Bran does in fact have the best
story.
Certainly better than Jon, a secret king who
literally came back from the dead to ride
a dragon into battle against an army of zombies
and tragically kill his aunt-slash-lover,
or Arya, who became a faceless assassin, got
revenge for her father's death by taking out
an entire noble house, and saved the entire
world by straight up shanking the Night King.
Maybe Westeros has a different idea of what
makes for a good story than we do.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.